Kraken CEO Dave Ripley on the business
implications of these new Bitcoin ETFs
and we're joined Now by Anthony Pompano
a founder of pomp Investments who
actually invested in the exchanges early
on coinbase for example but when you
look forward now in the era of a Bitcoin
ETF is a business model like coin bases
in severe threat frankly given the ETF
flow yeah I think the public markets
drastically uh underappreciate what
these businesses are right so if you
think about it everyone knows the
exchange business every knows the
custody business but coinbase has kind
of quietly been transitioning into a web
3 uh or kind of Crypton native uh
Revenue as well and so they have this
new blockchain base uh that's driving a
lot of Revenue and so really what I
think Public Market investors should be
thinking about whether it's coinbase or
other uh of these public companies is go
stack rank every single one of these
companies by what percentage of the
revenue comes Crypt native and the
higher the percentage of Crypt native
Revenue the more mispriced they probably
are in the public markets and I think
qub is a great example speaking of
crypto native you have kind of the ETF
you have other kind of of stocks tied to
the crypto industry but then you have
things that are actually decentralized
things that live in web 3 a word that we
don't hear a lot anymore on these
programs where is the value anymore as
an investor do you start to look at more
mainstream Bitcoin and the Bitcoin
related products that have attached to
Wall Street or do you look into web 3
well I think it's all the same thing
right if you really think about it
Bitcoin was the one that kicked off this
entire Revolution um when you look at
the monetary uh competition I think
Bitcoin is by far the winner uh now
there's going to be a big technology
competition and really when you look at
this sector I think a lot of people want
to put it in a separate bucket but I
look at this just as another macro asset
that you can go in and you can invest in
and so what we have seen is young people
specifically are putting their Capital
into this sector this sector has
outperformed drastically even with the
recent pull down you know Bitcoin is
still up like 75% or something and so I
think that investors who want to have
outperformance they're going to have to
allocate to the sector and the ones that
continue to fight it they're just going
to get left behind Anthony I want to get
back to the spot Bitcoin ETF discussion
but I have to ask you a little bit more
about coinbase obviously had a great
year last year up nearly 400% or
something like that you take a look at
the 2024 performance down what 28%
year-to date is that a dip that you're
buying um so coinbase we' just held the
uh position and what I think really
again it's the number one regulated
Exchange in America and so if you're
bullish on this sector you've got to be
bullish on coinbase another thing is
they're the custody provider for many of
these ETFs and so in some weird way
they're almost taxing the entire ETF uh
kind of trend and so I think coinbase
will continue to be a leader um and
overall that's good for the industry but
I also think it's good for Wall Street
right Wall Street doesn't just want to
have a bunch of assets that are sitting
there that they can't access if they're
on you know non-public exchanges and so
having a stock like coinbase that
they're able to allocate to I think is
actually good for them as well I want to
get a little bit philosophical here
because I'm looking at your notes you
write about this new regime that this uh
spot Bitcoin ETF approval is bringing
about different investors less
volatility more mainstream adoption less
volatility doesn't that just mean that
Bitcoin trading is going to become less
fun definitely I always joke that when
the suits show up the fun is over right
and so to some degree um if you really
think about what these new investors do
they have different behaviors right they
rebalance their portfolios historically
what's the meme bin hold right you don't
rebalance and so uh on top of that you
also will see a lot of use of
derivatives and so there is a lot of
capital that's going to flow into these
ETFs we're seeing that already but when
you start to see derivative usage I
think that some of that will pull away
it won't actually move the underlying
and so people just have to realize new
investors new behaviors uh the days of
th% returns in a single year are
probably over the good news is that an
80% draw down is much less likely
doesn't mean it won't happen but much
less likely now that volatility dampens
and you are indeed here in a suit today
uh you know you have Bitcoin ETF
approval but what about the rest of them
do you think an ETF tied to ethereum or
another type of crypto asset could make
as much sense this is one of my big bets
over the next couple of years so I think
that the altcoin ETFs are going to be a
massive area for Innovation and also
value to be created uh we recently uh
took one of our businesses reflexivity
research we sold it to a Canadian uh
publicly traded asset manager called
defi Technologies one of their
subsidiaries Valor this is their whole
strategy basically go and find all of
the altcoins That Wall Street wants
access to but they can't get access to
and create etps in Europe and so we
think that capital is going to flow
heavily into the Bitcoin uh ETF but it
also is going to flow into all of these
other assets but how do you parse what's
real from the noise and especially when
you think about the E uh the SEC and the
Crackdown they have on so many of these
tokens on so many of these exchanges how
do you make a bet on any of them there's
more nonsense in the public Equity
Market than there's in the crypto
industry in terms of these assets and so
when you really look at it is crypto is
a free market still for for many uh
purposes and so there's been a lot of
clearing out but the market has done
that right when you look at the public
markets I mean you guys cover almost on
a daily basis someone doing something
stupid a company that you know said it
was doing one thing and ended up not
being successful and so uh bad people
will do bad things markets will
ultimately kind of uh figure out who the
winners are but I do think that in this
sector there's a lot of people who have
said hey there's no value there right
you know Warren Buffett told me it's not
valuable but again these assets have
outperformed something like a birkar and
I think that people need to go spend the
time to actually learn about it I want
to talk quickly about stable coins
obviously one of the big conversations
in the crypto uh sphere over the past
few weeks has been about tether's
reserves obviously the CEO of cander
Fitzgerald saying that he's seen them
they're there is tether the stable coin
of the future so one of the interesting
things about tether and usdc usdc was
rising in adoption uh but it's a
regulated stable coin in the United
States and so actually people
internationally don't like that that is
a turnoff to them is that there's now a
coin that the United States government
has a lot of oversight in and so tether
has continued to see adoption go up uh
they are the 16th largest holder of us
treasuries at this point they are an
essential part of the American Financial
economy so what does that mean for
Circle then as it looks to IPO would you
be a buyer in IPO Stu I think circle's
an amazing business and especially with
high interest rates they're going to
continue to do very very well I think
again it's I'm an American sitting on
American soil right I look at these
things very differently than maybe
somebody does internationally but you
again we cannot discount if you're the
16th largest buyer of us treasuries at
the same time that China Japan Etc is
all buying treasuries less these things
are going to become a very very
important part and then also tether I
mean if you look at their numbers right
it's one of the most profitable
businesses on a revenue to uh employee
basis in the world and so instead of
attacking these types of businesses we
should be looking at and saying how do
we create more of these businesses but
next time let's not let it happen
outside the United States let's make
sure that it's based here in the United
States Anthony this was awesome got to
leave it there come back soon that is
Anthony Pompano of pomp Investments